Cuando estamos trabajando con aritmética básica
generalmente sabemos exactamente con que
números estamos trabajando,
tenemos 23 más 5 y haciendo esa suma nos queda 28 ó tenemos 7 por 3 ó tenemos 110 entre 11...
Pero bueno, el chiste es que aquí sabemos
con que números estamos trabajando ,
23, 5, 28, 7, 3, 110, 11... sin embargo,
conforme nos vamos metiendo al mundo algebraico,
nos vamos encontrando con cosas un poquito más abstractas, digamos...
seguramente ya te has encontrado
tú con algunas de estas...
estas variables... variables...
y estas variables, ya no son números fijos,
a estas variables las puedes ver de un montón
de formas, pero lo más importante es que
estas variables pueden cambiar sus valores,
o sea sus valores no están fijos, no son
exactamente 110, ni 7, ni 5... no está perfectamente determinado cuanto vale.
A ver, veamos un ejemplo.
Por ejemplo, "x" más 5, ok, esto de aquí,
todo esto junto, es una expresión.
Y la variable en esta expresión es ésta, es "x".
"x" es nuestra variable y cuanto vale "x"
depende del contexto, no es algo fijo,
y por lo tanto,
¿cuánto vale "x" más 5?
Tampoco es algo fijo.
Por ejemplo, si nosotros decimos que "x" es igual a 1...
a ver... si "x" es igual a 1... entonces...
"x" más 5 es igual a...
a ver aquí tenemos que la "x" vale 1, entonces
"x" más 5 vale 1 más 5 y eso es igual a 6.
Ahora, la "x" no tiene porqué siempre ser
igual a 1, ok, aquí estábamos en un escenario,
en un contexto en el que la "x" era igual
a 1, sin embargo también podría ser que
la "x" fuera igual a, no sé, -7, ok, vamos
a ver qué pasa en ese caso.
Si "x" es igual a -7, entonces "x" más 5...
pues aquí la "x", esta "x" vale,
en este contexto en el que "x" vale -7 pues vale -7,
así es que "x" más 5 es igual a -7 más 5...
-7 más 5, lo cual es igual a -2.
Ok, entonces éste es un muy buen ejemplo
de como la variable "x"dependiendo del contexto,
puedo tener distintos valores.
Ok, entonces ya vimos las variables dentro
de expresiones, pero las variables también
las podemos encontrar en las ecuaciones.
Ahora, hay que notar, es muy importante notar,
que las expresiones son distintas de las ecuaciones.
Ok, las expresiones son simplemente así,
un conjunto de símbolos que no tiene un igual
que simplemente expresan un valor, ok, aunque
no esté fijo ese valor...
A ver, por aquí pongamos expresiones...
expresiones...
Ok, las expresiones expresan cierto valor.
Un ejemplo de una expresión es como el que
ya vimos, "x" más 5, donde pues podemos sustituir
el valor de esta variable, como lo hicimos
aquí y dependiendo del valor que tome esta
variable, la expresión va a tomar cierto valor,
o sea, en este caso tomo el valor de 6, luego
en este caso tomo el valor de -2,
el chiste es que el valor de la expresión cambia, cuando
cambia el valor de la variable.
Ok, pero este no es el único tipo de expresiones,
también podemos tener una expresión que sea como,
"y" más "z" donde no hay ni un solo número fijo,
aquí todavía teníamos al 5,
pero aquí, estas dos son variables
no fijas y podemos sustituir a cada una de ellas
con distintos números, si "y" es 1 y "z" es 2,
entonces esta expresión va a ser 1 más 2.
Si por ejemplo ahora "y" es igual a 0 y "z" es igual a -1,
entonces esta expresión va a ser igual a 0 menos 1, ok.
Entonces las expresiones expresan un valor,
a diferencia de las ecuaciones,
las ecuaciones lo que hacen, es tomar expresiones e igualarlas a otras expresiones.
Las ecuaciones lo que van a hacer, es tomar
un signo de igual y poner una expresión de
este lado y otra expresión de este lado,
ok, entonces lo que hacen las ecuaciones es
decirnos que estas dos expresiones son iguales.
Entonces tenemos aquí a las, ecuaciones....
ecuaciones...
Que lo que hacen es tomar una expresión...
un ejemplo de una expresión es "x" más 3...
e igualarlo a otra expresión, que esta expresión
podría ser por ejemplo un 1,
ésta también es una expresión.
Hay algunos casos, como éste, donde la ecuación empieza a restringir...
que valores pueden tomar sus variables, ok.
Por ejemplo, si tenemos una sola ecuación,
tenemos una sola variable dentro de la ecuación,
entonces aquí ya sabemos exactamente cuanto
tiene que valer la "x",
para que se dé esta igualdad.
Ok, de hecho seguramente lo puedes
hacer en tu cabeza,
¿qué cosa si le sumas 3, te da 1?
Pues -2, si le sumas 3 te da 1, ¿cierto?
Y ademas es el único número que hace eso, ok.
Entonces nosotros sabemos que esta variable
tiene que valer -2, ok, entonces la ecuación,
esta ecuación, este signo de igual, está
restringiendo los valores que puede tomar esta variable.
Sin embargo, no todas las ecuaciones nos pueden
decir exactamente cuanto tienen que valer
las variables que se encuentran en sus expresiones, ok,
Por ejemplo, también podemos tener la expresión
"x" más "y" más "z", ésta es una expresión...
igualada a otra expresión, como por ejemplo
5, también es una expresión y esta ecuación,
no obliga a cada una de sus variables a tomar
un solo valor, éste es el ejemplo de una
ecuación que no obliga a sus variables a
tomar un valor fijo determinado.
Aquí, nosotros no podemos decir directamente
cuanto tiene que valer la "x", ni la "y",
ni cuanto tiene que valer la "z".
Ahora, aunque esta ecuación no determina
exactamente cuanto tienen que valer estas variables,
si las restringe un poquito, pero las restringe con respecto a lo que valen las otras variables.
Ok, por ejemplo, si nosotros sabemos cuanto
vale "y" y cuanto vale "z",
entonces ya podemos determinar exactamente cuanto vale "x"... ok, a ver...
Si "y" es igual a 3 y "z"...
bueno aquí vamos a ponerle una coma para
denotar el y porque si pongo un y va a parecer
una "y", pero bueno...
y "z" es igual a 2, ok, entonces aquí nosotros
tenemos que esto es igual a un 3
y esto es igual a un 2, al menos en este contexto.
3 más 2 es un 5,
entonces esta ecuación es igual a
"x" más 5 es igual a 5.
Ok, entonces podemos hacer esta cuenta en
nuestra cabeza y nosotros sabemos que entonces
esto implica que "x" es igual a 0, ok.
Entonces, esta ecuación, en este contexto
en el que "y" es igual a 3 y "z" es igual a 2, implica...
este símbolo es el símbolo de implica, significa más o menos un entonces, pero bueno...
Si tenemos esta ecuación y este contexto, entonces "x" tiene que ser exactamente igual a 0, pero bueno...
A ver, aquí hay dos puntos muy importantes.
Uno es que las expresiones son distintas de
las ecuaciones, ok, ésta es una expresión
y las ecuaciones son la igualdad entre dos
expresiones, ok, este es el primer punto.
El segundo punto es que las variables pueden
tomar muchísimos valores distintos, ok,
y dependiendo del contexto en el que se encuentren
pueden tomar un valor, pueden tomar algún otro,
pueden no estar restringidas y pueden
a fuerzas tener que ser iguales a cierto valor,
pero el chiste es que en general, no está fijo
cual es el valor que tienen que tomar,
o al menos todavía no sabemos cual es
el valor que tienen que tomar.
Ok, bueno, entonces para recalcar esto de
que las variables pueden tomar muchos valores,
vamos a evaluar un montón de expresiones
con distintos valores de alguna variable.
Entonces, por ejemplo, podemos tener la expresión
"x" a la "y", y "x" por ejemplo puede valer 5,
mientras que puede darse el caso de que
"y" valga 3, ¿cierto?
aquí no tenemos ninguna restricción con
respecto a cuanto pueden valer estas variables,
así es que escogemos dos números, en este
caso yo escogí 5 y 3 y vamos a evaluar esta expresión
cuando la variable "x", que no
necesariamente tiene que ser igual a 5,
pero en este contexto "x" va a ser igual a 5 y
en este contexto "y" va a ser igual a 3.
Ok, entonces evaluando esta expresión, en
este contexto, nosotros lo que tenemos es
5 elevado a la 3 y eso es simplemente 5 por 5 por 5...
5 por 5 por 5, que es igual a 125.
Ok, entonces vamos a poner otro contexto.
Tenemos la misma expresión pero ahora vamos
a ver el contexto donde "x" es igual a -2.
Y "y" es igual a, pues digamos que es igual a 2 también.
Ok, entonces lo que tenemos aquí es que "x"
es igual a -2 entonces tenemos aquí un -2
y tenemos que elevar a la "x", que es esta
"x", la tenemos que elevar a la potencia "y",
pero "y" es igual a 2, entonces aquí tenemos
un 2, ok, y esto es igual a -2 por -2,
menos por menos nos da más y 2 por 2 nos da 4,
así es que esto es igual a 4.
Pero, también podemos tener expresiones mucho
más complicadas, por ejemplo podemos tener
la raíz cuadrada de "x" más "y" menos "x",
¿les parece una expresión complicada?
Y entonces podemos evaluar esta expresión,
cuando la variable "x" es igual a 1 y la variable
"y" es igual a...
mmm... no sé... digamos 8.
Entonces sabemos que la "x" puede ser cualquier
otro número, pero escogimos el 1
y que la "y" puede ser cualquier otro número pero
escogimos el 8 y entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es cada vez que encontremos una "x"
en esta expresión,
la vamos a sustituir por un 1...
ok, aquí tenemos un 1, este es "y"...
y luego aquí tenemos otra vez otra "x", entonces
esto tiene que ser otro 1.
Y cada vez que veamos una "y", la tenemos
que sustituir por un 8.
Ok, entonces esta "y" es un 8 y entonces lo
que tenemos, es la raíz cuadrada de 1 más 8 menos 1.
1 más 8 es 9, entonces su raíz cuadrada es 3,
3 menos 1 es 2, así que esta expresión es igual a 2.